what we're going to do in this video is
do some practice examples of exercises
on Khan Academy that deal with
reflections of functions so this first
one says this is the graph of function f
fair enough
function G is defined as G of X is equal
to F of negative x also fair enough what
is the graph of G and on Khan Academy
it's multiple choice but I thought for
the sake of this video it would be fun
to think about what G would look like
without having any choices just
sketching it out so pause this video and
try to think about it at least in your
head all right now let's work through
this together
so we've already gone over that G of X
is equal to F of negative x so whatever
the value of F is at a certain value we
would expect G to take on that value at
the negative of that so for example we
can see that F of 4 is equal to 2 so we
would expect G of negative 4 to be equal
to 2 because once again G of negative 4
we could write it over here G of
negative 4 is going to be equal to F of
the negative of negative 4 which is
equal to F of 4 and so we could keep
going with that
what would G of negative 2 be well that
would be the same thing as F of 2 which
is 0 so it would be right over there
what would G of 0 be well that would be
the same thing as f of 0 because the
negative 0 is 0 and F of 0 is right over
there it looks like negative 2 and so
you can already see where this is going
and we've already talked about it in
previous videos that if you replace your
X with a negative x you're essentially
reflecting over the y-axis so G is going
to look something like this it is going
to look something like this once again G
of negative 6 would be the same thing as
f of 6 and so that would be the graph of
G and if you're doing this I'm kind of
got me to pick the choice that looks
like this that would give a reflection
over the y-axis let's do another example
so here once again this is the graph of
the function f and then they say what is
the graph of G and so pause this video
at least try to sketch it on your mind
what G should look like all right so in
this situation they didn't
place the X with negative x in f of X
instead G of X is equal to the negative
of all of f of X in fact we could
rewrite G of X like this we could say
that G of X is equal to notice all of
this right over here that was our
definition of f of X so G of X is equal
to the negative of f of X so instead of
it being F of negative x it's equal to
the negative of f of X so one way to
think about it is we can see that f of 0
is 2 but G of 0 is going to be the
negative of that so it's going to be
equal to negative 2 and so you could
keep going with that you could see that
whatever f of a certain value is G of
that value would be the negative of that
so it would be down here and so G of X
would be a reflection of f of X about
the x axis so G of X is going to look
something something like something like
that a reflection about the x axis and
so what's good I'm kinda gonna need to
pick the choice that would actually look
like that let's do another example this
is strangely fun alright so here we're
told functions f so that's in solid in
this blue color and G dashed so that's
right over there
our graphed what is the equation of G in
terms of f so pause this video and try
to think about it so the key is to
realize how do we transform f of X
actually they labeled it over here this
is f of X right over here in order to
get G so f of negative x would be a
reflection of f above about the y-axis
and so it would intersect there it would
have this straight portion like this and
I'm just experimenting right now how the
straight portion like this and then it
would go up and let's see F if F of
negative x so when you input 6 into it
that would be f of negative 6 which is 6
so it would go up there so F of negative
x would look something something like
this something like that so the purple
is F of negative x now that doesn't
quite get us
- gee but it gets it's a little bit
closer because it looks like if I were
to take the reflection of F of negative
x f of negative X about the x-axis it
looks like I'm going to get two G and so
how do you reflect something about the x
axis what we saw it in the example just
just now you multiply the entire
function by a negative so we could say
that G is equal to the negative of F of
negative x is equal to the negative of
this so we're doing both reflections
we're flipping over the y-axis and we're
flipping over the x axis to get to G
let's do one more example so once again
they've graphed f they've graphed G and
they've said f is defined as this right
over here
what is the equation of G so they're not
just asking it in terms of f they just
want to know what is the equation of G
pause this video try to think about it
well you can see pretty clearly that
this is a reflection across the y-axis
and a reflection across the y-axis you
can see pretty clearly that G of X is
equal to F of negative x f of negative X
how do we know that well for what
whenever we take f of X and we get that
value G at the negative of that value
takes on the same function value I guess
I could say or another way to think
about it is we could just pick this
point negative 8 f of negative 8 is
equal to a little over 4 but G of 8 is
equal to a little over 4 is equal to
that same value and so what is the
equation of G well we just have to
rewrite this so that we can write it out
as an equation and so we could write out
G of X is equal to if I were to replace
all of the X's here with a negative X
what would I get I would get 4 times the
square root of 2 - instead of an X I
will have a negative x and then the
minus 8 is outside of the radical and so
we would have G of X is equal to 4 times
the square root of 2 plus X minus 8 and
we're done